The arrival of Stinger, Kang's new fashion
sense, and a familiar looking cantina.
The "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania" trailer
was filled with Easter eggs you might have
missed.
Forget about saving the universe, Scott Lang's
greatest accomplishments are the victories
he encounters in his everyday life.
For example, in "Ant-Man and the Wasp," his
daughter gives him a "World's Greatest Grandma"
trophy, which, at the time, was the best birthday
present Scott ever received.
However, that accolade pales in comparison
to being hailed as one of the best workers
ever to grace the ice cream industry.
The "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania" trailer
notes that Scott is Baskin-Robbins' "Employee
of the Century."
And that's in addition to being an ex-con,
successful podcaster, and member of the Avengers.
He even stops by in his Ant-Man suit to accept
the award, showing just how far he's come
since his days of being down on his luck.
It's great to see that superheroism hasn't
made Scott forget about his days working in
an ice cream parlor.
Furthermore, the trailer also reveals that
Dale will be part of "Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania," as one scene shows Scott shaking
hands with his old manager.
The "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania" trailer
doesn't explain specifically how the Ant-Man
family gets sucked into the Quantum Realm.
We can only assume that it's because the film's
primary villain, Kang the Conqueror, somehow
uses Cassie's new tech for his own schemes.
Throughout the trailer, Janet seems terrified
of anything relating to the Quantum Realm,
saying that there's some information she didn't
share with everyone else.
"There's something I never told you…"
The trailer makes it seem like she's talking
about Kang, who looks to be in control down
there, or at least has a very imposing presence.
Could Kang be the reason why everyone's in
the Quantum Realm?
Is he chasing after Janet for something she
did there?
Did Cassie's technology somehow "awaken" him?
MCU fans will remember that "Ant-Man and the
Wasp" revealed that Janet spent 30 years in
the Quantum Realm before Scott rescued her.
There's no telling what kind of trouble she
got into during that time, but "Ant-Man and
the Wasp: Quantumania" will definitely give
us some answers.
The clue was in the title as to where Scott
and Hope would spend their next adventure,
but now the new trailer confirms that they're
not the only ones headed to the Quantum Realm.
After Cassie's quantum satellite apparently
makes contact with all the wrong people, all
of Ant-Man's allies are pulled along with
him into a strange new world.
"It's a secret universe beneath ours."
From here, the trailer lays on the stunning
and surreal vistas of the Quantum Realm pretty
thick.
This latest installment of Ant-man's story
feels less like it's pulled off of a comic
book page, but instead from a classic science
fiction movie involving another small adventure.
This could very well be Scott Lang's own "Fantastic
Voyage," the classic 1966 film with a group
of explorers shrunk to microscopic size who
traverse the insides of a living human body.
While there doesn't seem to be any human test
subject in the area when they're shrunk down,
"Quantumania" seems to match the epic adventure
on a tiny scale.
One shot suggests that when they arrive, the
group ends up scattered across this unknown
territory.
This could lead to some father-daughter time
with Scott and Cassie, and Hope getting the
opportunity to know the mother she thought
she lost forever.
It's hard to ignore the fact that a bar seen
during our peek into the Quantum Realm as
the trailer plays out feels like a visual
callback to the "Star Wars" saga.
The circular half-bar, its multi-armed bartender,
and the well-packed room definitely harken
back to the Mos Eisley Cantina.
The bar in the trailer seems to have more
of an air of sophistication that Mos Eisley
lacks.
But several patrons are seen wearing brown
cloaks reminiscent of Obi-Wan Kenobi and his
protegé Luke Skywalker.
The earth-toned outfits feel like a callback
to the Empire, and many of the characters
seen within the establishment resemble the
rubber-faced puppets of the sci-fi classic.
In "Ant-Man and The Wasp: Quantumania," however,
there's a lot more neon involved, and the
lighting is generally warmer in tone.
There are also what appear to be strange hookahs
sitting on several of the tables.
Fans will have to wait to see how these devices,
and the bar itself, will be used in the film.
Cassie is one of the most significant reveals
in the "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania"
trailer.
She shows her dad the device she helped make,
which communicates with the Quantum Realm.
After the group is sucked into the realm,
we see Cassie in her regular street clothes
with her dad.
Eventually, toward the end of the trailer,
we see Scott, Hope, and Cassie all in special
suits as they stare down someone off-screen.
While we've seen Scott and Hope's suits before,
Cassie's is new.
It looks like we might see Cassie take on
the mantle of "Stature" in the third "Ant-Man"
flick.
We first saw poster art of Cassie's purple
suit at San Diego Comic-Con 2022, and now
it's finally a reality.
In the comics, Stature makes her debut in
2006's "Young Avengers" #2 and later becomes
Stinger in 2016's "Astonishing Ant-Man" #6.
Cassie's powers are very much like that of
Scotts, but they can often be connected to
her emotions.
It seems like "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania"
will introduce us to a new MCU hero who could
appear in future films.
All it took was a scene-stealing monologue
in "Loki" and blurry camera footage from D23
to get fans hyped about Jonathan Majors' next
take on Kang.
An outstanding performance was always guaranteed,
but the fact that this appearance would potentially
be completely different from what we had before
was even more exciting.
It only takes a few seconds to confirm that
this Kang isn't quite as jovial as the one
before, and he might have some plans for…conquest.
"So, what's it gonna be…Ant-Man?"
In the trailer, we first get a good look at
him in his iconic get-up from the comics,
which originates from the 40th century.
From there, the Conquerer-to-be is shown having
a brief chat with Scott, with Kang coming
off as far more threatening than the jokey
anarchist we met before.
Our only questions are how Scott will hold
off against this new and unknown threat, and
will the joint help of Cassie and Hope be
enough to ensure that the Kang Dynasty is
held off for as long as possible?